monte
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans en séance aujourd'hui nous allons
revenir sur l'examen de la proposition
de loi concernant le volontariat des
sapeurs pompiers le texte a été adopté à
l'unanimité le 23 septembre dernier au
sénat il prévoit notamment une série d'
avantages sociaux une amélioration de la
retraite pour les pompiers au bout de
dix ans d'engagement mais aussi des
promotions pour les pompiers volontaires
qui aurait accompli des actes de
bravoure et enfin la mise en place d'un
numéro d'urgence unique le sens d'où ce
qui remplacerait tous les autres numéros
je voulais revivre ces débats
avant de vous présenter la position du
ministère de l'intérieur sur la
proposition de loi je souhaite d'abord
évidemment profité cet instant pour
rendre depuis la tribune du sénat un
hommage aux personnels de la sécurité
civile son engagement au service des
français et sans faille quotidien
constants il y à un départ en
intervention des sapeurs comme si toutes
les sept secondes en france cet
engagement conduit parfois au sacrifice
suprême qui fauche dans leur jeunesse
dans leur force des femmes et des hommes
engagés au service des autres à cette
heure je veux commencer par avoir une
pensée pour pierre françois bonnard 38
ans mécanicien opérateurs de bord de la
base aérienne de grenoble mort en
intervention il y a dix jours
le 12 septembre et j'ai également une
pensée pour brian rimbaud sapeurs
pompiers volontaires de 23 ans décédé en
intervention dans la somme
ces drames humains ils illustrent au
plus haut point le sens élevé du service
public de la grande communauté de la
sécurité civile sapeurs pompiers
militaires professionnels et volontaires
marins pompiers sapeurs sauveteurs des
formations militaires de sécurité civile
pilote agents du groupement des moyens
aériens fonctionnaires du déminage tous
et chacun en ces grades et qualités à
son poste à sa responsabilité au service
des françaises et des français et cette
tradition de cergy cette force de
mobilisation le gouvernement est bien
sûr les français la connaissent et la
reconnaissent je voudrais donc avant
d'en venir au détail de la ppl salué
l'action de ces femmes et ces hommes qui
tous les jours par de secours à nos
concitoyens je crois que collectivement
nous en sommes fiers fiers de ce modèle
de sécurité civile qui suscite des
demandes toujours plus nombreuse de
coopération à l'international
fier d'une organisation solide qui s'est
toujours adapté pour faire face aux
nouvelles menaces preuve en est la
formidable mobilisation de la sécurité
civile dans la gestion de la crise
sanitaire ainsi quand il a fallu donner
cet élan nouveau renforcé décisif à la
campagne de vaccination contre le coc
u19 les services d'incendié et de
secours ont su se mobiliser selon les
excuses de la direction générale de la
sécurité civile et sous la direction
opérationnelle des préfets ils sont
ainsi présents dans 201 centres de
vaccination dont 119 directement placées
sous leur autorité et aujourd'hui encore
plus de 5500 sapeurs-pompiers oeuvrent
quotidiennement pour vacciner l'ensemble
de la population
lorsqu'il a fallu mettre en place dans
les meilleurs délais les contrôles aux
frontières extérieures pour pratiquer
les tests la force humaine des services
d'incendié secours et des associations
agréées de sécurité civile là encore a
été au rendez vous plus de huit cent
vingt mille passagers ont été testés par
les équipes réparties sur tous les
points d'entrée des ports et des
aéroports nationaux internationaux
parlent cet été après s'être engagé sur
de multiples théâtre extérieur italie
grèce algérie nos services d'incendié et
de secours appuyés par les formations
militaires de sécurité civile sont venus
à bout de l'incendié qui ravageait le
massif des maures je salue la
mobilisation là encore total des sapeurs
pompiers leur professionnalisme leur
dévouement exemplaire cet été pour
lutter contre les feux de forêt et cet
engagement du quotidien nous oblige
c'est donc le sens de la proposition de
loi visant à consolider notre modèle de
sécurité civile et valoriser le
volontariat des sapeurs pompiers déposé
par monsieur le député fabien matras
cette proposition de loi a été adopté en
mai dernier à l'assemblée nationale
unanime t et le sénat on a été saisi
dans la foulée et a réalisé un travail
de grande qualité et je veux ici saluer
chaleureusement l'investissement sur ce
texte des trois rapporteurs madame
françoise dumont monsieur loïc arget
monsieur loïc karzaï à m'excuser
monsieur patrick kanner et je tiens à
vous remercier en mon nom de mise
l'intérieur gérald darmanin pour la
fluidité des échanges et pour le climat
constructif dans lequel ces échanges se
sont toujours déroulées je sais que nous
allons avoir des débats sur certains
points je sais aussi que nous pourrons
dégager des consensus utile et je sais
que s'agissant de la protection de nos
concitoyens les opinions et les avis
divergent finalement peu est en
discussion de cette proposition de loi
nous avons tous et tout un objectif
commun partagé très largement trans
partisan offrir le meilleur service de
secours aux français la proposition de
loi visant à consolider notre modèle de
sécurité civile et valoriser le
volontariat des sapeurs-pompiers et les
sapeurs pompiers professionnels apporte
des avancées attendues par l'ensemble
des acteurs de la civil de la sécurité
civile vous le savez parfaitement et le
gouvernement les soutient consolider
notre modèle de sécurité civile pour
nous cela signifie avant tout conforter
le volontariat l'engagement citoyen le
volontariat sa spécifité cette
spécificité française si précieuse qui
permet à notre modèle de porter secours
à l'ensemble de nos concitoyens en tout
temps en toutes circonstances en tout
point du territoire la solidité de ce
modèle repose sur les deux cent mille
femmes et hommes qui en parallèle de
leur travail de leur étude de leur vie
personnelle ou familiale volontairement
donnent de leur temps s'engage pour
venir secourir les autres ces deux cent
mille femmes et hommes ils sont aux
côtés des sapeurs pompiers
professionnels et militaires le pilier
de notre organisation de secours et ils
doivent je crois le demeurer alors pour
conforter le volontariat il faut
l'encourager il faut le valoriser car si
l'engagement ne recherche pas la
rétribution et doit néanmoins être
reconnu pour que ce modèle se renforce
et qu'il perdure la gratitude de la
nation doit pouvoir s'exprimer
pleinement quand les citoyen s'engage
pour la servir et la rendre toujours
plus fort toujours plus unis plusieurs
mesures figurent dans cette ppl pour
aller plus loin dans la reconnaissance
et la valorisation du volontariat
l'abaissement du seuil de déclenchement
de la nouvelle prestation de
fidélisation et de reconnaissance le
miso l'intérieur à d'ailleurs un champ
des changes avec les financeurs désiste
pour la revalorisation
lui-même qui relève du pouvoir
réglementaire promotion au cadre
d'emplois au grade ou à l'échelon
supérieur selon les cas pour les
fonctionnaires décédés en service ou
grièvement blessées création de la
qualité de pupille de la république
notamment pour les enfants des sapeurs
pompiers professionnels ou volontaires
tu es mise en place de dont deux jours
de congé au bénéfice de sapeurs pompiers
volontaires vous le savez le minot
l'intérieur gérald darmanin et moi même
nous sommes d'ardents défenseurs de cet
engagement citoyen qui n'est ni du
bénévolat denis juste à l'arrière et qui
ne doit pas s'en approcher il faut à la
fois le faciliter en permettant une
meilleure conciliation du volontariat
avec l'exercice de l'activité
professionnelle mais aussi l'encadré
pour éviter que certaines pratiques
minoritaires ne le déstabilise nous
devons aussi et surtout le conforter
dans sa spécificité au regard des règles
européennes après la jurisprudence
malzac et à la suite de notre saisine la
commission européenne le gouvernement
français a obtenu une réponse qui
confiant bien la solidité du système du
volontariat la lecture en séance
publique au sénat est l'occasion de
mieux prendre en compte dans le texte le
rôle essentiel des associations agréées
de sécurité ségéla c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement va soutenir plusieurs
amendements visant par exemple à mieux
préciser le champ des réserves de
service d'incendié et de secours qui
n'ont pas vocation à agir sur le même
périmètre de mission que les asc ou
autre exemple réprimer plus efficacement
les structures qui bien que dépourvu
d'agrément se permettre d'agir sur le
terrain le gouvernement sera aussi
favorable à l'amendement 166 proposé par
les rapporteurs à l'article 34 en effet
nous partageons avec madame et messieurs
les rapporteurs clairement l'importance
de la reconnaissance par la nation de
l'engagement des bénévoles de ces
associations agrées la meilleure
reconnaissance du rôle de ces assauts de
ces associations dans cette proposition
de loi nous semble être une brique
majeures apportées par le sénat par
ailleurs cet été se contente pas
seulement de consolider le volontariat
elle conforte l'ensemble du modèle de
services de sécurité civile d'abord elle
est plus fort que les missions des
sapeurs pompiers qui ont évolué au cours
des 15 dernières années elles ont changé
de nature le secours d'urgence aux
personnes est devenue en quelques
décennies l'activité principale des
services d'incendié et de secours ils
représentent désormais plus de 80% des
interventions dans la très grande
majorité des cas les sapeurs pompiers
interviennent en étroite collaboration
avec les acteurs de santé au premier
lieu les services du samu centre 15
c'est toujours en totale complémentarité
et sur le terrain avec un très grand
professionnalisme qu'ils interviennent
ensemble pour offrir le secours le plus
rapide et le plus optimal aux victimes
je tiens à le souligner il ya là d'une
certaine manière urgence à tirer toutes
les conséquences de cette évolution en
adaptant la loi et nos doctrines
opérationnel aux réalités de terrain il
ya une certaine urgence à reconnaître
les missions de sapeurs foncé et ce dans
toute leur globalité y compris celles
qui sont liées aux soins qui peuvent
être prodigués aux personnes secourues
c'est tout le sens de l'article 2 de
cette proposition de loi la proposition
de loi traite également dans son article
3 du sujet majeur des carences
ambulancière qui sont un enjeu important
du fonctionnement actuel des services
d'incendié et de secours l'assemblée
nationale a aussi permis aussi de
retrouver la maîtrise et la priorisation
de ses moyens en permettant la
temporisation et l'engagement la
commission des lois du sénat a souhaité
introduire la requalification sur ce
dernier point il semble important au
gouvernement de pouvoir essayer de
respecter les équilibres trouvés entre
les services dans son discours et les
structures d'aidé médicale d'urgence
c'est pourquoi nous proposerons un
amendement de rétablissement du texte
sur ce sujet la présente proposition de
loi apporte aussi beaucoup en termes de
doctrine d'intervention d'organisation
de fonctionnement des services
d'incendié et de secours le gouvernement
a apporté des amendements sur les packs
capacitaire les contrats territoriaux de
réponse aux risques et aux effets de
menaces à l'assemblée nationale nous
soutenons les amendements devant le
sénat qui vise à élargir les communes
soumises à la réalisation de ligue à
thouars du plan communal de sauvegarde
les expériences récentes nous montre à
quel point ces pcs même simple et des
exercices réguliers peuvent réussir à
sauver des vies car c'est bien de cela
dont il s'agit et c'est cela qui guide
ensemble nous réflexion et notre action
autre enjeu majeur pour conclure dans
l'organisation des secours le traitement
de la laërt l'article 31 de la
proposition de loi va permettre
d'expérimenter ce fameux numéro unique
des appels d'urgence dans le droit fil
de l'engagement pris par le président de
la république alors je sais que certains
jugent que cette écriture pu être plus
ambitieuse je les entends mais
j'aimerais aussi dire qu'il nous faut
embarquer tous les acteurs de cette
expérimentation
elle ne sera pas dilatoire elle sera
vraiment fondatrice les préfets et les
directeurs généraux des récents
dresseront le bilan et sur cet article
également le gouvernement proposera un
amendement pour préserver des équilibres
qui avait pu se dégager à l'issue de
l'examen de l'assemblée nationale
l'article 9 de la proposition de loi
très de la modernisation de notre
dispositif de prévention le déploiement
du sel broadcast que nous avions
annoncée pour 2022 cela permet
d'améliorer en temps réel l'alertent et
l'information des populations en cas de
survenance d'un événement majeur il
permettra une diffusion machine
diffusion prioritaires et rapide aux
populations exposées à un risque avec
des informations essentielles à leur
protection cette proposition de loi est
ainsi devenu au gré des apports
successifs hier de l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui et dans les prochains jours
du sénat du gouvernement constamment le
support juridique d'une rénovation
véritablement profonde de notre modèle
de sécurité civile avec un objectif
toujours partagé d'une excellence
opérationnelle au service des français
et d'une reconnaissance forte et claire
des sapeurs-pompiers et de leurs actions
j'en souhaite l'adoption rapide adoption
que je souhaite évidemment la plus
unanime possible nous aurons je le pense
de riche et fécond débat avant d'y
parvenir mais je ne doute pas que nous
parviendrons ensemble à atteindre
l'objectif tant attendu je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la ministre la parole est
maintenant madame françoise dumont au
rapporteur de la commission des lois
pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois mes chers collègues depuis de
nombreuses années la commission des lois
donnent dans la sécurité civile la place
primordiale qu'elle mérite c'est la
raison pour laquelle elle a désigné pour
cette proposition de loi trois
rapporteurs appartenant aux trois
principales sensibilités politiques de
notre assemblée cette configuration
aurait sans doute été impossible sur
d'autres sujets ou en d'autres lieux
mais elle n'a posé aucun problème aucune
distension temps nous savons à quel
point les enjeux de cette proposition de
loi sont fondamentaux pour notre nation
toute entière je tiens ici à remercier
chaleureusement loïc hervé et patrick
kanner grâce à qui la qualité de notre
travail a été je pense à la hauteur des
enjeux en effet initialement déposée par
le député fabien matras puis soutenu par
le gouvernement
ce texte entend se placer dans la lignée
des grandes lois de sécurité civile au
même titre que celle de 1996 relatif aux
services d'incendié et de secours de
2004 portant modernisation de la
sécurité civile c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous n'avons pas hésité à
considérer que certaines dispositions du
texte transmis par l'assemblée nationale
étaient de véritables avancées qu'il ne
fallait pas remettre en cause par
principe cette objectivité nous conduit
aujourd'hui à partager un certain nombre
de points de vue avec le gouvernement en
revanche nous avons été particulièrement
vigilants lors de l'examen des
dispositions qui n'en portait pas de
consensus sur le à leur sortie de
l'assemblée nationale les plus sensibles
concernent l'expérimentation des
plateformes communes de réception des
appels d'urgence l'article 31 de la
proposition de loi initial prévoyait la
mise en place du 112 comme numéro
d'appel d'urgence unique ainsi que la
mutualisation des plateformes de
réception des appels d'urgence très
attendu par les acteurs de la sécurité
civile ce dispositif a toutefois soulevé
de vives protestations de la part des
acteurs de la santé qui ont qui ont vu
une remise en cause possible du principe
de la régulation médicale et du service
d'accès aux soins récemment mis en place
la commission des lois ne remet pas ici
en cause son souhait de voir aboutir à
terme un numéro unique et des
plateformes communes ce souhait a
d'ailleurs été confortée par notre
déplacement sur la plateforme commune de
réception des appels d'annecy toutefois
nous avons considéré que les conditions
n'étaient pour l'heure pas réunies pour
la mise en place définitive d'un tel
système sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
la commission a donc conservé le
principe d'une expérimentation mais a
apporté des modifications non certaines
sont pour nous clairement indispensable
la première concerne la mise en la prise
en compte des associations agréées de
sécurité civile dans le dispositif dont
elle était exclu et ce malgré le
caractère incontournable de leur action
la deuxième temps à mettre les
présidents de se disent concernés sur le
même plan que le représentant de l'état
où le directeur général de l'agencé
régionale de santé dans la mise en
oeuvre de l'évaluation des
expérimentations
enfin la troisième temps à prévoir qu'en
cas de succès de l'expérimentation un
référentiel national relatif au
fonctionnement des plateformes serait
élaborée par l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés dans le respect des
prérogatives de chacun cette logique de
dialogue et des changes semble
impérative pour mener à bien un tel
projet de mutualisation madame la
ministre ces modifications ne relève que
du seul mon sens et pourtant vous
souhaitez tout les remettre en cause
sans exception par l'amendement que vous
avez déposé nous aurons donc l'occasion
d'y revenir un peu plus tard
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur patrick hannais
rapporteur de la commission des lois
pour 3 minutes vous avez la parole
monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
sa collègue rapporteur je rejoins la
position de madame françoise dumont que
je souhaite à mon tour remercié avec le
qu'hervé pour le travail que nous avons
mené ensemble d'une entente totale et
sincère la posture permettez moi c'est
l'expression du gouvernement quant aux
avancées de la commission des lois
m'interroge cela a été rappelé de notre
côté nous avons au contraire salué les
avancées du texte transmis au sénat je
fais ici référence aux articles 1er 2 et
3 qui vient utilement clarifier le cadre
d'interventions des services d'incendié
de secours sous cette année sous
certaines réserves comme l'expliquera
dans quelques minutes notre collègue
louis qu'hervé jeu fait également
référence aux articles 20 et 21 qui pour
le premier prévoit des promotions à
titre exceptionnel pour les sapeurs
pompiers volontaires ou professionnels
décédé lors de leur service ou ayant
commis des actes de bravoure et pour le
second créer une mention mort pour le
service de la république au bénéfice des
personnes appartenant à des corps ou
entités habituellement exposés à des
situations de danger tout en ouvrant le
nouveau statut de pupille de la
république pour l'heure orphelins mais
la ministre malgré vos salutations
amicales nous ne sommes pas naïfs le
projet de loi déguisée que nous
examinons aujourd'hui a mis près d'un an
à être inscrit à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée nationale son examen a été
repoussée de mois en mois quand le
gouvernement n'y trouvait pas à l'époque
d'intérêt immédiat dans la ministre si
aujourd'hui la procédure accélérée a été
enclenchée par le gouvernement si ce
texte qui concerne directement les
départements été transmis au sénat en
plein milieu des élections
départementales
nous avons dû examiner en commission au
mois de juillet au pas de course sous
une grêle de projet de loi si une cmp va
être convoqué dans des délais records
ses 10 ans le simplement parce que le
congrès de la fédération nationale des
sapeurs pompiers se tient au mois
d'octobre à marseille et que vous
souhaitez naturellement y faire bonne
figure avec une loi a présenté par le
président de la république lui-même nous
ne sommes pas donc les supplétifs d'un
gouvernement déjà en campagne
présidentielle permettez moi de vous le
dire et nous n'hésiterons pas à
repousser l'entrée en vigueur du texte
de quelques semaines s'il en va de
l'intérêt des actrices et des acteurs de
la sécurité civile nous attendent
vis-à-vis du gouvernement dépasse ce
texte je fais ici référence à la
jurisprudence match ac qui a été évoqué
par notre collègue en face du monde et
vous même d'ailleurs qu'il n'ya plus
besoin de présenter dans notre hémicycle
et par laquelle la cour de justice de
l'union européenne considère que les
sapeurs pompiers volontaires peuvent
être assimilés à des travailleurs certes
l'article 22 à de la proposition de loi
tend à contrer cette jurisprudence vous
l'avez rappelé mais son niveau
législatif le rend parfaitement
inopérant face à une jurisprudence de
niveau européen ce texte très clairement
est l'occasion pour nous de vous
demander madame la ministre et au
gouvernement s'il compte soumettre une
réponse juridique effective à ses
partenaires européens à l'occasion de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne c'est l'occasion ou jamais de
faire bouger les lignes là la ministre
vous l'aurez compris nous sommes là pour
défendre l'intérêt général pouvez
compter sur nous et l'intérêt général ne
se résume pas à la course un peu contre
la montre que vous imposer dans le cadre
de l'agenda parlementaire mais sachez
que nous serons constructif pour
préserver la sécurité civile de notre
pays je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président la parole est maintenant
monsieur loïc hervé est rapporteur de la
commission des lois pour 3 minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues l'arrêt madsack et
l'expérimentation des plateformes
uniques n'ont pas été les seuls sujets
d'attention de notre commission des lois
la proposition de loi se penche
également sur le problème épineux des
carences ambulancière relever dès 2016
par le rapport de la commission des lois
du sénat intitulé secours à personnes
propositions pour une réforme en
souffrance les carences ambulancière
recouvre les cas où à la demande du samu
le sdiss réalise des transports
sanitaires pour pallier l'absence
d'autres moyens dont ceux des
ambulanciers privés ces carences ont
dénoncé par les acteurs de la sécurité
civile car d'une part la qualification
d'une mission en carence relève
principalement au delà de l'appréciation
du médecin régulateur du samu et d'autre
part le montant de l'indemnisation des
10 s'élève à 123 euros par carence alors
que le coût moyen qu'ils supportent est
estimé entre 450 et 500 euros en outre
ces créances sont parfois difficilement
recouvrées par les 10 in fine et le
développement de ces carences ajouter à
leur mauvais remboursement conduite un
transfert de charge de fait entre le
niveau national qui finance les seules
les familles et les collectivités
territoriales au premier rang desquels
les départements et les communes qui se
financent les 10 nous avons donc il
était très défavorable à l'article trend
pardon nous avons donc été très
favorable à l'article 3 de la
proposition de loi qui donne une
définition objective de la carence
ambulancière c'est une vraie avancée
qu'il faut reconnaître néanmoins la
commission des lois a jugé utile
d'adopter un amendement qui tend d'une
part à supprimer l'obligation de
prescription médicale pour pouvoir
qualifier une intervention de carence
ambulancière et d'autre part à rétablir
la possibilité de procéder à la
requalification a posteriori de cette
carence cette précision permettra aux
dix d'être justement indemnisés
lorsqu'ils ont réalisé l'intervention à
la demande du 15 quand il s'est avéré
par la suite qu'elle relevait en
pratique de la carence ambulancière cet
égard je comprends mal l'amendement du
gouvernement qui propose la suppression
de ce que nous avons apporté son examen
l'examen de cet amendement nous
permettra de débattre de ce point enfin
je souhaite finir sur un point positif
puisque certains apports de la
commission des lois n'ont pas fait
l'objet d'amendements du goût ni du
gouvernement ni la part de de vous mes
chers collègues
le premier porte sur la mise en place de
référents sécurité au sein des indices
ils seront notamment compétent pour les
questions relatives à la prévention des
violences commises contre les sapeurs
pompiers il s'agit de l'une des
propositions du rapport de la commission
des lois de 2019 sur la sécurité n'est
sapeurs pompiers et le second concerne
la possibilité ouverte à l'ensemble des
conseillers municipaux de représenter
leur commune ou leur pc eee au conseil
d'administration 10 10 alors que cette
faculté est actuellement ouverte qu'au
maire ou aux adjoints cet apport fait
écho à la création par la proposition de
loi d'un correspondant incendie et
secours au sein de chacun des conseils
municipaux mes chers collègues madame la
ministre ce dernier mois point me pousse
à être optimiste quant à l'avenir de ce
texte nous sommes persuadés que la
sagesse du sénat ne manquera pas de
persuader n'ont qu'à les députés c'est
en tout cas le souhait que nous
formulons avec françoise dumont et
patrick kanner merci le 21 3 m en
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
le 36
madame mary l'un va le présenter merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous partageons bien
évidemment la volonté de donner la
qualité de pupille de la nation aux
enfants des sapeurs pompiers tués dans
des circonstances et que la loi propose
de préciser par la mention de mort pour
le service de la république mais il nous
semble qu'on pourrait faire les choses
si je peux le dire ainsi un peu plus
directement et
de se garantir que les enfants en
question puisse réellement bénéficier du
statut aux côtés de celui des pupilles
de la nation et donc dans un objectif de
clarté de simplification nous proposons
non pas qu'il y ait des renvois à ce
statut particulier mais qui leur soit
directement attribués qu'ils bénéficient
bien de la même protection que les
pupilles de la nation et donc qu'on
inscrive directement dans le texte sans
passer par les renvois tels qu'ils sont
exprimés aujourd'hui merci merci madame
rollin nous passons à l'avis de la
commission
pas pardon oui excusez mon en discussion
commune le 84
c'est monsieur du rhin qu'il présente
merci madame la présidente l'article 21
de la proposition de loi crée un nouveau
statut de pupille la république pour les
orphelins des personnes dont l'acte de
décès portent la mention mort pour le
service de la république militaire ou
agents publics appartenant à des corps
ou entités habituellement exposés à des
situations de danger telles les agents
de police les sapeurs pompiers
professionnels ou volontaires les agents
des douanes ou de l'administration
pénitentiaire ainsi que les sauveteurs
en mer cet article important il a
concrétisé un engagement du président de
la république il permet à l'état d'
exprimer sa gratitude et sa
reconnaissance de manière officielle
envers ceux qui meurent en service il
permettra à leurs enfants d'être
soutenus et accompagnés en tant que
pupille de la république nous vous
proposons de parachever la création de
ce nouveau statut afin de devenir en
complément des dispositifs qui existent
déjà nous pensons qu'il est utile de
conforter des missions protection et
soutien matériel et moral apporté aux
enfants des sapeurs pompiers et des
personnels de la sécurité civile a
accompli par l'oeuvre des pupilles
orphelins et le fond d'entre elles des
sapeurs pompiers de france au dp comme
le fait le fils national des anciens
combattants et victimes de guerre pour
les militaires dans le cadre du statut
de pupille l'eau dpe est une association
à but non lucratif créée en 1926 et
reconnue d'utilité publique depuis 1928
elle prend actuellement en charge plus
de 1416 orphelins de sapeurs pompiers
l'ajout proposé nous semble nécessaire
cet amendement s'inscrit dans la logique
d'une structure adaptée et nous paraît
de se réapproprier s c'est pour ça que
nous vous proposons de l'adopter si
chers collègues et le 69 rectifier les
présentée par monsieur chasse est
exactement le même amendement qui vient
d'être décrit par mon collègue merci
chers collègues est donc maintenant nous
passons à l'avis de la commission sur
ces trois amendements identiques
présidente sur l'amendement numéro 36
alors que le projet de loi prévoit de
créer une qualité de pupille de la
république qui seraient attribuées aux
enfants des personnes dont l'accueil de
décès portent la mention mort pour le
sauver de la république
madame assassi propose que c'est aux
enfants bénéficient directement la
qualité pupille de la nation des
existantes il hésite cependant la
distinction entre le statut proposé de
pupille de la république et celui
existant de pupille de la nation
contrairement au plus vite la nation il
ne serait pas nécessaire pour lui
reconnaître la qualité de pupille la
république que l'enfant soit adoptée par
la nation en conséquence la qualité de
pupille de la république n'entraînerait
aucun rôle particulier de l'état en
matière de tutelle ou de placement de
l'enfant cette évolution nous a semblé
de nature à simplifier la gestion de ce
nouveau pupilles à qui serait centrée
sur les aides apportées par l'état en
matière éducative sociale et fiscale
c'est pourquoi il nous semble pertinent
de conserver la création du pia de la
république davy la commission est
défavorable
il ya les deux autres avant pardon
pardon pardon messieurs rapporteur il ya
trois amendements et donc pour les deux
amendements suivant dans la présidente
de 84 69 rectifié messieurs du rhin et
chassaing propose de confier à l'oeuvre
des pupilles orphelins du fonds
d'entraidé des sapeurs pompiers de
france l'accompagnement des enfants des
sapeurs pompiers personnels de la
sécurité civile public de la république
si nous comprenons l'objectif poursuivi
l'attribution de l'accompagnement des
pupilles de la république à telle ou
telle organisera les bras d'une
convention entre le cet organisme et
l'état il va mais c'est nécessaire de
définir les aides financières attribuées
par l'état pour cet accompagnement ce
que nous ne pouvons pas faire dans la
loi donc c'est une demande de retrait
pour ces deux amendements et à défaut
nous est défavorable
merci et donc maintenant madame la mise
sur ses trois amendements
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et les
sénatrices je serai un petit peu longue
exceptionnellement compte tenu de la
sensibilité du sujet d'abord je veux
commencer par dresser en notre nom à
tous une pensée à toutes les ottou les
enfants et à toutes les familles
endeuillées qui peut être sont en train
de regarder nos débats pour répondre au
premier amendement le numéro 36 c'est un
moment qui souhaite donc attribuer le
statut de pupille de la nation aux
orphelins dont le parent décédé et
reconnu mort pour le service de la
république joe d'abord rappelé que le
statut de pupille de la nation il est
intimement lié au code des pensions
militaires d'invalidité et des victimes
de guerre dans la mesure où leurs
flingues et éligibles dès lors que son
parent a notamment par exemple été tués
ou est mort de blessures ou de maladies
contractées ou aggravées du fait d'un
événement de guerre ou une opex c'est à
dire des circonstances qui rendent
éligible pardon d'être un peu
administrative à la mention mort pour la
france peuvent également être pupille de
la nation les orphelins d'agents publics
tués du fait de l'acte volontaire d'un
tiers ou d'un acte de terrorisme
tel que prévu par le code et qui ont
vocation à être bénéficiaire entre
guillemets de la mention mort pour le
service de la nation le gouvernement
propose dans le cadre de l'article 21
que les enfants demandent 22 ans des
personnes reconnues morte pour le
service de la république du fait
notamment de l'accomplissement de leurs
fonctions dans des conditions impliquant
un danger ou un risque particulier non
liées à l'acte volontaire d'un tiers
puissent aussi bénéficier de la qualité
de pupille de la république si les deux
statut de pupille sont formellement 10
tort juridiquement les droits associés à
la qualité de pupille de la république
sont par équité pour les orphelins
endeuillée par le décès tragique de l'un
de leurs parents très similaires à ceux
octroyés aux pupilles de la nation en
particulier pour ce qui concerne la
matérialité de l'accompagnement qui leur
est dispensée et les aides financières
qui leur sont bien légitimement accordé
en outre je veux dire que le pupille à
de la république ne prévoit pas comme le
pupille de la nation de procédures
d'adoption devant le juge il en résulte
du coup certes une moindre charge
symbolique mais aussi surtout une plus
grande facilité et un délai
potentiellement raccourci pour la mise
en place de l'accompagnement ce qui a
été relevé dans tous les travaux
préparatoires ce sont les raisons pour
lesquelles le gouvernement est né un
avis défavorable à ce premier amendement
en ce qui concerne les amendements
numéro 84 et 69 rectifier ce sera une
demande de retrait je veux dire que le
présent article précise dans la ville et
dans l'alinéa pardon 25 que l'office
national des anciens combattants et
victimes de guerre peut se voir confier
par convention pour le compte de l'état
l'accompagnement des pupilles de la
république sa disposition à londres elle
ouvre donc déjà une possibilité qu'il
était indispensable de prévoir
explicitement pour que cet opérateur de
l'état avec des missions bien délimitées
puis se voir confier pour le compte et
par financement d'un ministère autre que
celui des armes et le suivi des pupilles
de la république une telle disposition
ne nous semblons pas nécessaire pour
confier cette mission à une association
dédiée en fonction des métiers et en
l'espèce les sapeurs comme c'est
l'opportunité de confier cette mission à
une association à but non lucratif au
moyen d'un financement unique de l'état
et sous son autorité doit faire l'objet
d'études trail à des notes amant
juridique et c'est pour toutes ces
raisons que le gouvernement propose de
retirer cet amendement et à défaut
émettra un avis défavorable je vous
remercie pour votre attention merci
madame la ministre oui il ya une demande
d'explication vote je vous en prie chers
collègues merci madame la présidente
nous allons retirer notre amendement
convaincu notamment et ce n'est pas pour
vous faire offense madame la ministre
par les arguments du rapporteur puisque
effectivement
le le fait de dettes du pis de la nation
implique une adoption par un action et
on comprend bien la charge symbolique
affectif psychologique ça peut
représenter nous souhaitions simplement
et je pense que nos collègues sont dans
le même état d'esprit
insisté et garantir que les enfants en
question soient accompagnés bénéficie du
même soutien que les pupilles de la
nation mais je crois qu'on a eu des
garanties en ce sens je vous remercie si
madame brulin et donc le 36 est retiré
il en va de même pour le 84 il est
retiré le 69 rectifié monsieur chassaing
et retirer je vous remercie nous passons
aux 129 il est présenté par monsieur et
merci madame la présidente chers
collègues l'article 21 du projet de loi
tant utilement à créer une mention mort
pour le service de la république ainsi
que la qualité de public publie de la
république pardon pour les enfants au
des personnes auxquelles cette mention
aura été attribués en revanche les
alinéas vingt à vingt-deux introduit
lors de l'examen en commission du tour
du sénat vise à préciser au sein de la
linea 400 11-6 du code des pensions
militaires d'invalidité et des victimes
de guerre l'impossibilité de cumul du
bénéfice de ce dispositif avec d'autres
dispositifs de protection existants or
ce principe de non cumul est d'ores et
déjà traités au niveau de l'année à 18
de l'article dont je vous ferai grâce de
la lecture exhaustive donc tout
simplement le précédent amendement le
présent amendement pardon propose en
conséquence de supprimer les années à
20,22 de l'article 21 qui apparaissent
redondant avec son alinéa 18 est
superfétatoire merci si chers collègues
avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
la présidente nos collègues du groupe r
des pays souhaitent pas l'amendement
supprime et une coordination nous avons
apporté en commission estimant qu'elle
serait superflu car le non cumul des
régimes et déjà prévues par ailleurs or
le principe même des coordinations est
cependant de faire en sorte que
l'ensemble des dispositions de notre
législation soient harmonisées entre
elles puisque nous sommes d'accord sur
le fond dispositif je ne vois pas pour
un pas qui je ne vois pas qui une
difficulté parce que non cumul de
qualité de pépites la république avec
d'autres dispositifs de protection soit
expressément indiqué à d'autres endroits
de notre corps législatif qui traite de
non cumul non me demande de retrait ou
un avis défavorable
merci madame la ministre
avis favorable madame un précédent avis
favorable
je mets aux voileux 120 le 129 qui a
reçu un avis d favorable de la
commission favorable du gouvernement qui
et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté nous passons 108 rectifié bis
c'est monsieur leroy qui le présente
merci madame la présidente manara
ministre jusqu'à présent le ministre des
armées pourrait décider d'attribuer la
mention mort pour le service la nation
bénéficé d'une part des militaires tués
en service ou en raison de leur qualité
de militaire et d'autre part des autres
agents publics tuées en raison de leurs
fonctions aux qualités la nr 23 de
l'article 21 que cet amendement se
propose de supprimer ajoute une
condition à cette attribution à savoir
que le décès soit intervenu du fait de
l'acte volontaire d'un tiers nous
considérons que ces hommes et femmes
engagés est morte par nation méritent
une juste reconnaissance tel et
l'amendement notre collègue henri leroy
merci monsieur bio quoi
elle nous passons à l'avis de la
commission
et qui présente avis de la commission
c'est monsieur hervé maintenant la
président de la création d'une nouvelle
mention mort pour le service de la
république porté par l'article 21 de la
proposition de loi vise cependant à
mieux reconnaître l'engagement
exceptionnel des personnes qui laissait
dans l'exercice de leurs fonctions la
mention mort pour le service de la
nation sur est réservé aux personnes
tuées parce qu'elle représentait dans
leurs fonctions la république tandis que
moore pour le service de la république
acterait par reconnaissance de la france
pour le reggae venant d'une personne
ayant conduit à son décès cet effort de
distinction me paraît louable et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je vous propose
de retirer votre amendement le demande
de retrait ou un avis défavorable merci
madame la ministre mais magique la
commission madame la présidente remercie
il est retiré merci monsieur burgoa le
108e retirer je mets aux voix levante
l'article 20 et qui est pour
et qui est contre s'abstient il est
adopté je mets aux voix l'article 21 bis
même vote il est adopté article 22 à
trois amendements identiques qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 30
sept
c'est madame kenobi merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues on a souvent tendance à dire
qu'il vaut mieux éviter les oies
bavarder cet article en est certainement
un bel exemple même si elle nous pouvons
en comprendre le sens et la volonté
d'être un bouclier à la menace aux
européennes planant sur notre modèle de
sécurité civile largement dépendant du
volontariat mais qui d'ailleurs pèsent
aussi sur bien d'autres engagements
bénévoles et volontaires sur d'autres
secteurs cependant ces conséquences
juridiques ne peuvent être à la hauteur
de ses ambitions puisque de fait et cela
aussi à rappeler souvent le droit
européen prime sur le droit français ce
premier constat nous amène donc comme
d'autres collègues ici à demander la
suppression de cet article pour faire un
appel au gouvernement sur son absence de
porter la directive européenne sur le
temps de travail de 2003 puis la
jurisprudence mazza de 2018 applique en
effet aux pompiers volontaires des
règles sur l'aménagement du temps de
travail comme le plafonnement à 48
heures par semaine de l'activité cumulée
entre travail et volontariat le repos de
sécurité quotidien et le paiement des
cotisations salariales nous partageons
bien évidemment l'inquiétude générale
face à l'application de ces règles en
france où le statut de pompier
volontaire est largement majoritaire et
je crois que c'est beaucoup m'ont redire
depuis hier et qu'il nous faut savoir
préserver protéger en l'articulant bien
évidemment avec une présence d'un
certain nombre de pompiers
professionnels
cependant comme je les dis le présent
article ne résout nous le problème de
l'application du droit européen ni les
dérives qui peuvent parfois apparaître
sur la situation du statut de volontaire
du statut pardon de pompier volontaire
c'est pour toutes ces raisons que nous
proposons la suppression de cet article
ces chers collègues nous passons à la
présentation du 104 par monsieur
benarroch oui merci madame la présidente
pas pas grand chose à rajouter en fait
aux propos de patrick kanner la
discussion générale et à ceux de madame
que romana les stores j'entends la
volonté du gouvernement de sauvegarder
le modèle de volontariat au coeur de
l'organisation des pompiers de
nombreuses questions ont été posées dans
cet hémicycle depuis le début des débats
pour vous alerter sur cette nécessité
très forte d'intervenir afin de
préserver ce modèle nous ne pensons pas
que l'article valdoie pourra suffire ni
qu'ils aient une cale courte portée
offrant une sécurité juridique trop bas
toi aussi au travers de notre demande de
suppression commune il ne faut
absolument pas voir notre opposition à
la préservation du volontariat tout au
contraire une eau trop fort attachement
à ce dernier et nous souhaitons donc un
engagement fort du gouvernement pourrait
intervenir au niveau de la
réglementation européenne en particulier
à l'occasion de la prochaine présidence
française de cette communauté européenne
merci chers collègues et maintenant le
162 présentée par monsieur k n'est pas
porteur oui madame la présidente
communisme et chers collègues on arriva
à l'un des points durs de ce texte
manifestement le fameux arrêt match ac
la directive de 2003
nous partageons je devance la vie qui
sera émis par les rapporteurs sur les
deux amendements présentés à l'instant
par nos collègues
il est clair que cette jurisprudence
appliquée au système français de
sécurité civile qui compte je le
rappelle 80% de sapeur pompier
volontaire aurait des conséquences
insurmontable pour l'organisation du
travail mais aussi pour le financement
de ces sapeurs pompiers volontaires cela
conduirait à plafonner leur nombre
d'heures de mission est rémunéré
l'ensemble des gardes répondant à
certains critères fixés par cette
jurisprudence
jurisprudence qui commence à voir des
extensions madame arrivé hier l'a évoqué
très clairement très clairement
notamment sur les militaires
donc nous sommes un peu entre le marteau
et l'enclume entre notre attachement à
l'union européenne et la réalité du bon
fonctionnement et souverain des
instances françaises en matière de
volontariat c'est un sujet qui remonte
pas à hier je voudrais vous rappeler le
rapport de même tremblé que chacun ici
apprécié pour son engagement sur la
question notamment des sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires en mai 2018 le rapport de
cette mission volontariat remis au
ministre de l'intérieur de l'époque
gérard collomb était sans appel nous
demandons au président de la république
et au gouvernement d'exprimer une
position politique déterminée auprès du
conseil de l'union et de la commission
européenne pour exempter exemptés
laissez pas pompier volontaire de toute
application de la directive sur le temps
de travail
qu'en est-il devenu depuis il ya eu là
des réponses 15 février 2019 commission
européenne
à mon avis insatisfaisante essayant de
nous rassurer il y a eu aussi les
tentatives du gouvernement de la
ministre vous les avez rappelé hier dans
votre intervention au plateau nous
sommes inquiets pour le dire très très
simplement et nous pensons que
finalement la suppression de cet article
22 portées par les rapporteurs et par
d'autres groupes ici présent est une
manière de vous interpeller pour quelle
occasion encore une fois de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne nous puissions faire évoluer
le droit en application
parce qu'aujourd'hui l'article 22 tel
qu'il est rédigé n'a aucune portée
juridique face à la cour de justice de
l'union
merci monsieur le rapporteur nous
passons dont l'avis de la commission est
favorable donc nous passons à l'avis du
gouvernement la ministre
merci madame la présidente mesdames les
sénatrices et mais sur les sénateurs
argentan l'interpellation de monsieur le
président et à travers lui de la
commission et du sénat et c'est pourquoi
nous allons donner un avis de sagesse
mais je souhaite néanmoins pouvoir
apporter des éléments de réponses
d'abord lors de la discussion à
l'assemblée nationale
il a été largement partagée le fait que
la mesure proposée à cet article en
portaient essentiellement un soutien
clair au volontariat et voulait
réaffirmer par une mesure adoptée à
l'unanimité sur tous les bancs que
l'activité de sapeur-pompier volontaire
ne puisse pas être assimilée à celle de
travailleurs pour autant bien sûr le
gouvernement partage le point de vue des
rapporteurs sur le caractère coopérants
de la mesure portée par cet article est
d'ailleurs c'est pour cette raison
essentiellement que nous nous en
remettons à la sagesse de votre
assemblée sur cet amendement je souhaite
néanmoins pouvoir profiter cette
discussion et de cet amendement pour
vous préciser qu'après un travail
soutenu avec les services de la
commission européenne nous avons pu
conforter la position de la france sur
l'absence d'applicabilité de la tirer de
la directive du 4 novembre 2003
concernant certains aspects de
l'aménagement du temps de travail la dtt
ainsi l'arrêt malzac de la cour de
justice de l'union européenne n'implique
nullement que tout sapeur pompier
volontaire devrait automatiquement être
considéré comme un travailleur au sens
de la dtt c'est très clair pour autant
ces gestes ces échanges ne permettent
d'offrir des garanties raisonnable pour
faire durer notre modèle de volontariat
que pour autant que l'on traite les
situations locales minoritaires
probablement qui pourraient les
fragiliser devant les juridictions il
nous semble en effet utile de préciser
que ces échanges ne lit en rien la
commission une juridiction nationale
alors que des contentieux sont déjà en
appel en france que certains renvoi
préjudiciel
pouvant avoir un impact sur les
activités de sapeurs pompiers sont en
cours et qu'il nous faut encore agir
pour traiter au mieux ses fragilités en
ce sens nos services ont annoncé une
large concertation visant tout d'abord à
disposer d'un point précis de situation
de l'organisation du recours au
volontariat dans les services d'incendié
et de secours ainsi que des propositions
concrètes qu'ils peuvent faire pour
traiter les fragilités qu'ils auraient
identifier cet état des lieux qui est en
cours de consolidation il sera suivi par
la mise en place de groupes de travail
constitués comme le ministre de
l'intérieur s'y est engagé pour partager
les constats et pour identifier les
nouvelles actions correctrices à
entreprendre ensemble à l'issue de ces
travaux deviendra le troisième temps
celui des ajustements ils n'auront pas
vocation à imposer des contraintes
inadapté aux territoires mais au
contraire à poser les bornes acceptable
est nécessaire au respect des exigences
de l'union européenne vous l'aurez
compris ces mesures elles doivent être
de nature à nous prémunir des fragilités
et jockeys face à de possibles
contentieux plusieurs d'entre vous
d'ailleurs ont évoqué l'occasion de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne je vais y revenir rapidement
pour dire que la france prendra une
initiative pour la valorisation de
l'engagement citoyen et ce travail
complémentaire il permettra d'asseoir
davantage notre modèle de sécurité
civile comme vous pouvez le constater le
gouvernement est pleinement engagée en
liaison étroite avec les services
d'incendié et de secours et l'ensemble
de leurs acteurs et partenaires dans la
consolidation de notre modèle de
volontariat et je sais pouvoir compter
sur vos analyses et bien sûr vos
propositions je vous remercie merci
madame la ministre je vais donc passer
la parole pour commencer à monsieur
chassaing pour explication de vote
madame la présidente madame les
ministres mes chers collègues donc je
termine à mon tour sur cet article a
fait l'objet comme il vient d'être dit
par la mesnie snow large consensus à
l'assemblée nationale bon si je
comprends les arguments juridiques et
l'objectif louable de la commission je
veux quand même rappeler les
conséquences de la décision européenne
m'attaque qualifiant les sapeurs
pompiers volontaires de travailleurs
seront lourdes pour eux également pour
notre système de secours
l'article qui a été écrit à une portée
limitée par rapport à la directive
européenne si le temps d'intervention
des sapeurs pompiers volontaires étaient
comptabilisés dans le temps de travail
cela équivaut à supprimer une très
grande partie des sapeurs pompiers
volontaires qui sont souvent à plus de
80 pour cent mille rural ce serait donc
catastrophique
j'ai eu l'occasion à deux reprises de
pose et de poser une cage et sur le
sujet durant les deux dernières années
sans recevoir pour l'instant de réponse
satisfaisante du gouvernement sauf sa
volonté de faire avancer le sujet je
connais les difficultés du dossier au
niveau européen l'engagement de la
france à surmonter mais une solution
devient désormais urgente si la
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne
doit nous aider à faire avancer ce
dossier ce que je souhaite sachez que
nous restons vigilants et qu'une
solution doit être trouvée rapidement
merci merci monsieur chassaing madame
arrivée vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente nous n'avons
pas présenté d'amendements dans ce sens
là pour notre groupe parce que
l'amendement de des rapporteurs présenté
en commission nous sembler satisfaisant
et j'ai souligné on dirait en dg que
nous félicitions les rapporteurs et que
nous suivions les emmener rapporteur je
voulais juste ajouté par rapport aux
propos de madame la ministre que
faire un bilan pour savoir où on en est
alors qu'on sait tous qu'on à 80% de
volontaires ce chiffre est suffisant
pour aller directement au but monsieur
chatel a souligné nombre de questions
orales questions écrites et le rapport
de madame tremblay montre qu'il fallait
de manière urgente régler le problème
juridique et les réponses comme je les
souliers dans la dg hier sont des
réponses incantatoire et cet article est
un article incantatoire et je dirais
même qu'il risque d'être contre
productif par rapport à l'union
européenne parce que quand on inscrit
dans la loi on veut que ça soit
appliquée et le jour où on est devant
une jurisprudence européenne qui ne
tient pas compte de ça et bien c'est
facile de dire c'est la faute à l'europe
et en ce sens c'est contre productif par
rapport à notre désir à tous de faire
avancer l'union européenne notamment sur
cette question là et donc ça devient
vraiment une question politique de
modèle social et à partir du moment où
il ya une jurisprudence qui touche aussi
la question de l'armée avec la dernière
jurisprudence par rapport à l'état
slovène eh bien il faut vraiment aller
droit au but et apporter une solution
juridique mais qui demande une
détermination politique merci chers
collègues la parole est un monsieur
bonhomme
merci mme la présidente oui monsieur
monsieur mini madame le ministre moi ça
fait effectivement depuis de nombreuses
années maintenant que nous souhaitons
sortir de ce point de blocage à venir
cet article me parler l'occasion
vraiment de d'insister sur les
conséquences de cet arrêt du 21 février
2018 qui attribuer la qualification de
travail aux sapeurs-pompiers volontaires
et qui en application des directives sur
la durée du temps de travail et les
temps de repos
tout le monde l'a dit ici et surtout les
bons je crois à peu près cela menace
fortement notre système de sécurité
civile ça fait plus de trois ans que
nous vous alertons régulièrement ce
sujet là
surtout dans les 10 les plus ruraux ceux
qui font appel aux plus aux volontaires
jeudi 80 % moyenne mais il ya des en
gros c'est beaucoup plus encore est on
bien c'est impraticable à terme les
conséquences seraient évidemment
dramatique sur le plan opérationnel sur
le plan budgétaire évidemment sur le
plan organisationnel en plafonnant le
nombre d'heures de mission et en
rémunérant l'ensemble des temps de garde
qui répondrait aux critères fixés par
cette jurisprudence alors et puis le
sénat lui-même a fait ce travail là je
rappelle que notre ancien collègue
catherine troendlé dans le cadre de son
rapport sur mission volontariat avaient
déjà alerté le mistral terre de l'époque
gérard collomb je rappelle que également
les avis budgétaire sur la sécurité
civile sur le programme sans son auteur
avait aussi pointé ses difficultés
insurmontables
notre collègue richard par la commission
envoie de la commission des affaires
européennes allaient également
fait de même donc se traitent ces
alertes j'aime dire général et répétés
sur la pérennité de notre dispositif de
sécurité civile personne ne peut
l'ignorer mais depuis chaque fois vous
avez intérêt à interpeller vous les
membres de gouvernement vous avez à peu
près fait à peu près les mêmes réponses
dilatoires ou lénifiantes à savoir merci
de nous alerter merci de donner pleine
conscience de ces difficultés et vous
venez à nouveau de renouveler
l'opération madame la ministre mais il
faudrait peut-être chaque fois ne pas ça
remettra nouvelles possibilités à savoir
aujourd'hui la présidence de la france
au sein de l'union européenne pour ne
toujours trouver des manières dilatoires
et finalement de gagner du temps le
problème c'est que maintenant les 10
sont de plus en plus inquiet et à chaque
réunion des pompiers on évoque les mêmes
problèmes et aujourd'hui je m'excuse
mais nous n'avons pas avancé mais pas
toutes les lettres qui ont été ici
renouvelé merci chers collègues il n'y a
plus de demandes d'explications de vote
je mets donc aux voix les trois
amendements identiques de suppression
que reçu un avis favorable de la
commission et une sagesse du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient ils sont
adoptés je mets au revoir à bas il est
supprimé l'article
nous arrivons à l'article 22 et nous
avons une demande de parole de madame 2d
à
madame la présidente madame le ministre
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues avant tout je
précise que cette prise de parole était
je l'apprends lieu et place d'elisabeth
doisneau très bien la présente
proposition de loi se donne pour
objectif de consolider notre modèle de
sécurité civile qui repose à plus de 80%
sur des sapeurs pompiers volontaires et
de conforter leur engagement de
volontariat ainsi l'article 23 clarifie
la notion d'accident de service pour une
meilleure prise en charge est
sapeur-pompier volontaire par la
sécurité sociale l'article 24 bis permet
aux sapeurs pompiers volontaires 2000
bénéficié de dons de jours de congé et
l'article 22 prévoit un abaissement de 5
ans de la durée d'engagement ouvrant
droit à la nouvelle prestation de
fidélisation et de reconnaissance je me
félicite que le sénat ait renforcé cette
démarche nos collègues rapporteurs ont
réécrit l'article 30 afin de faciliter
l'attribution du label employeur
partenaires des sapeurs-pompiers et la
mise en oeuvre du mécanisme de réduction
d'impôt au titre du mécénat au bénéfice
d'un dispositif de réduction de
cotisations sociales patronales
déjà adopté par le sénat lors de
l'examen du plfss 2010 9 je les dis
l'article 22 prévoit donc un abaissement
de cinq ans ce choix comprend au vu de
la nécessité de ne pas renforcer la
notion de travailleur au regard de
l'impasse de la rue balzac en effet de
nombreux éléments concourent déjà un
risque d'assimilation des sapeurs
pompiers volontaires au statut de
travailleur le fait qu'il soit indemnisé
soumis à un respect de règles notamment
un lien de subordination et qu'il ne
puisse totalement vaquer librement à
leurs occupations
notamment cependant il faudra pas faire
preuve de pédagogie auprès des premiers
intéressés qui pour certains jugent ce
nouveau dispositif décevant par rapport
à d'anciennes piste longtemps envisagé
comme la bonification en trimestres de
retraite mais qui s'avère incompatible
à l'heure actuelle avec l'arrêt malzac
c'est notre devoir en tant que
parlementaire de favoriser de
reconnaître l'engagement de ceux qui
risquent leur vie au service de
l'intérêt général
souhaitons que ce texte qui contribuent
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues et nous passons
donc maintenant la présentation du 163
et il est présenté alors messieurs
caennais avant de précision dans leurs
villages je vous remercie
madame la ministre
ali favorable d'un président je vous
remercie je mets donc au voilà moment 60
163 de la commission qui a reçu un avis
favorable qui est pour
quiconque qui s'insèrent est adopté je
me vois l'article 22 kg et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
petit peu 25-10
124 rectifier
mme ana moura
merci madame la présidente ses talents
novice à favoriser l'accès des sapeurs
pompiers volontaires au logement social
en prévoyant des objectifs d'attribution
à l'image du dispositif récemment
adoptée à l'égard des personnes exerçant
une activité professionnelle dans un
secteur essentiel
il s'inscrit dans le travail initié par
le sénat à l'occasion du projet de loi
3ds qui en est à prendre en compte le
besoin de logements à proximité de leur
travail pour les travailleurs clé
exerçant dans un secteur concourant à la
continuité de la vie de la nation les
sapeurs pompiers volontaires qui assume
à la fois des missions de secours et de
soins dont la crise sanitaire
tu es le caractère indispensable doivent
être inclus dans ce dispositif eu égard
au caractère indispensable du
volontariat qui représente 79% du corps
des sapeurs pompiers français et sur
lequel repose l'essentiel de notre
modèle de protection civile il apparaît
juste et proportionnée de favoriser
l'engagement par l'amélioration des
conditions matérielles et logistiques de
nos hommes en les intégrant aux
dispositifs susnommé merci chers
collègues monsieur le rapporteur
et je chante pas entendre la position
qui vient d'être faite par notre
collègue
c'est un amendement qui prévoit donc la
détermination par convention
intercommunale d'attribution d'objectifs
d'attribution de logement social aux
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires pour les
rapprocher de leur lieu de travail
chacun a bien compris il vise ainsi à
poursuivre avec plus d'efficacité
l'objectif posé par l'article 25 bis de
la proposition de loi que nous venons
examinera l'instant mes chers collègues
donc cet amendement propose une
imputation dans le code de la
construction de l'habitation qui semble
plus adéquate et est un dispositif plus
opérants nous émettrons un avis
favorable même si nous avons une
discussion sur le fait qu'ils aient
c'est pas toujours évident de donner
priorité à autant de priorités quand il
s'agit de trouver un logement social
néanmoins donc l'intention est louable
avis favorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre
oui merci madame la présidente mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs le projet de
loi cadets on a rappelé comporte dans
son volet logement social un objectif
d'attribution de ces logements pour ceux
qu'on appelle les travailleurs clés de
la nation et bien sûr les sapeurs
fonction est évidemment vocation à
entrer dans ce cadre c'est pourquoi nous
souhaitons que le dispositif qui est
porté dans le pg cadets puisse être
privilégiée dès lors il nous apparaît
pas souhaitable de devoir modifier la
proposition initiale de cet article au
risque d'avoir deux dispositions
concurrentes et donc inopérante endroit
ensuite donc en conséquence même si nous
partageons l'objectif je vous propose de
retirer votre amendement pour plus
d'efficacité à la rédaction des lois et
à des fois ce serait un avis défavorable
du gouvernement
merci même la mini jeux vous maintenez
votre amendement chers collègues et donc
je vais mettre aux voix la maman 124
rectifié qui a reçu un avis favorable de
la commission défavorable gouvernement
qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté et donc l'article 25 bis est
ainsi rédigé nous passons à l'article 31
et nous avons deux demandes de parole
d'abord monsieur dit benarroch merci
madame la présidente
l'expérimentation qui est proposée par
cet article 31 par part d'une d'une idée
logique puisque effectivement la
régulation et les transferts d'appels
peuvent parfois amenés à des délais
supplémentaires dans le déploiement de
l'assistance
je ferais remarquer que nous devrions
plus parler d'ailleurs d'une plate forme
de traitement unique avec eux regroupés
dans un même lieu plutôt que d'un numéro
unique plusieurs fois cependant après
également notre vigilance tout d'abord
en tant que représentant des territoires
je pense que nous pourra témoigner en
tout cas je peux le faire dans le mien
de territoire que cette coordination
souhaité peu existait déjà dans certains
endroits même si elle n'est pas
formalisé de la même façon que par cette
expérimentation
aussi cette expérimentation et son
analyse devra prendre en compte les
équilibres existant déjà à ce jour il
est possible que cela soit ici réel
apport pour certains territoires
mais que là les éléments les
spécificités des initiatives locales des
en place amènerait en fait à une
désorganisation inutile si nous
généralisons cette expérimentation
les questions opus de leadership dans la
prise de décision ou d'organisations sur
le long terme d'une telle plateforme
unique doivent s'accompagner d'une
réflexion accrue sur les mécanismes de
financement et de compensation s'il est
retenu que les médecins samu organise
des sorties d'urgence des pompiers pour
répondre aux appels il devient
responsable nous l'avons déjà dit d'une
des pages départementales aller vers si
les pompiers s'en chargent de faire
sortir des véhicules samu dans le cadre
de cette expérimentation et les engage
une dépense ne relevant plus de leur
budget aux deux ans de guerres de
clocher qui peuvent exister la
responsabilité des dépenses devraient
aussi être abordées en amont de cette
expérimentation enfin ce numéro unique
ne doit pas cacher les difficultés qui
vont arriver en aval
j'ai pu le rappeler mais que ce soit les
paupières ou le samu le point d'arrivée
de cette prise en chasse sont toujours
et toujours les urgences hospitalières
la crise sanitaire a à perdre a permis
d'observer une spectaculaire baisse de
la fréquentation des urgences mais ces
services reviennent peu à peu saturé la
réflexion du numéro unique de sorhea
trop découplé de la réflexion sur le
service accès aux soins sas actuellement
lui-même en expérimentation qui pourrait
être associé ce service d'ailleurs à une
télé consultation aussi en l'état actuel
notre groupe votera pas cet article qui
n'apporte pas les garanties d'une réelle
réflexion de voir des par tous pour une
expérimentation plus l'âge de la prise
en charge
merci monsieur benarroch avant de donner
la parole à monsieur cigolotti
de vous informer qu'il nous reste 37
amendements nous savons qu'en
discussions et nous avons un rythme
plutôt soutenu depuis ce matin donc
juste je joue dit qu'on a la possibilité
si les uns et les autres le souhaitent
d'aller et au terme de ce la discussion
de ce texte avant la coupure à condition
que chacun évite d'être trop bavard
voilà ce que je peux vous dire tout en
étant efficace et en défendant ses
arguments évidemment donc je laisse la
parole à monsieur siglé d'un merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues avec cet article 31
nous abordons un des points clés de ce
texte la mise en oeuvre des plateforme
regroupant les numéros d'appel d'urgence
lors de la discussion générale nous
rapporterons clairement précisé leur
souhait de ramener la durée de
l'expérimentation de trois à deux ans ce
à quoi nous souscrivons totalement
cependant sur ce point nous pensons
qu'il existe d'ores et déjà des
plateformes techniques 18 15 dans
certains départements et c'est le cas
dans mon département de la haute-loire
en capacité d'accueillir les différents
opérateurs de l'urgence
cependant toute évolution sera
impossible tant que l'état ne
s'impliquera pas au plus haut niveau est
temps que chacun des deux ministères
concernés intérieur et santé s'obstinera
à jouer sa propre partition
au nom des différences de culture alors
que les professionnels de santé et de la
sécurité civile peut s'entendre sur le
terrain une volonté de travailler
ensemble est absente au niveau national
l'enjeu est pourtant simple il s'agit
d'optimiser l'usagé des moyens seul à
même de préserver la qualité du service
public une plus grande efficacité un
meilleur emploi des moyens dédiés au
secours passe nécessairement par des
coordinations renforcé et des
mutualisations élargie à travers nos
échanges sur cet article 31 nous
souhaiterions pour notre groupe avoir
l'assurance que le gouvernement entend
bien procédé à la mise en oeuvre de
plate forme départementale
regroupant à minima le 15 et 18 et non
des plateformes supra départementales
voire régionales
comme le prévoit le projet marcus
cigolotti et nous passons maintenant à
l'examen des amendements le 19 rectifié
bis
monsieur ça drôle de le descendre à
l'homme la ministre
madame terre chaque collègue
jeu
j'entends par cet abonnement demandé la
suppression de l'article 31 il vise à
instituer ça vient d'être dit un numéro
unique des services d'incendié et de
secours mais c'est l'expérimentation
annoncé ne doit pas masquer des
inconséquences manifeste du projet
rapidement
d'abord la mise en oeuvre d'une
plateforme commune au service incendie
et secours et au service d'aidé médicale
d'urgence
il est notoire que les services
dell médicale d'urgence sont opposés à
la mise en place non concertée d'un tel
dispositif
d'ailleurs les assistants de régulation
médicale du cac se sont mis en grève
dans une quarantaine de stats de sa but
à la suite de l'annoncé de ce projet
ensuite parce que les départements ça
vient d'être dit qui assure le plus gros
des finances font des dix
souhaitent légitimement avoir la
maîtrise des moyens engagés lors des
interventions pour pouvoir en contenir
les coûts ce qui ne serait pas le cas
également parce que c'est même ce 10 et
donc une grande partie des départements
ont déjà contribué à hauteur de plus de
neuf millions d'euros auprès de la nfc
pour le projet de luc si c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas été remboursés à la
connaissance de ses avances
également et le sénateur fogel je pense
est avec nous parce que dans son rapport
au nom de la commission des finances du
2 juin dernier il a émis de nombreuses
réserves sur le montage juridique et
financier de l'opération lors de
l'examen du rapport en commission
beaucoup d'ailleurs évoqué le souvenir
douloureux
du projet antarès qui avait bousculé
beaucoup le fonctionnement baisse 10
mais surtout le fait qu'il existe
actuellement en france des plateaux
commun dans plusieurs départements qui
permettent de réunir 10 et samu c'est le
cas dans une vingtaine de départements
et un des rapporteurs connais
parfaitement
le plateau commun du département de la
haute savoie donc pour toutes ces
raisons
il me paraît mal venu sans concertation
préalable et dans un contexte juridique
et financier plutôt mal ficelé
d'envisager une expérimentation telle
qu'elle est proposée ci sert collègues
nous passons maintenant à l'avis de la
commission
madame le rapporteur madame la
présidente c'est cet amendement est
contraire à la position de la commission
il tend à supprimer l'article 31 de la
proposition de loi qui tend vous le
savez à créer un cadre pourrait
expérimenter des plateformes communes de
réception des appels d'urgence en vue de
la mise en place d'un numéro d'appel
unique les arguments développés par
l'auteur de l'amendement sont certes
audible mais nous continuons de penser
que des plates formes communes et un
numéro unique sont des avancées
nécessaires
néanmoins nous estimons que les
conditions ne sont pas réunies pour les
généraliser aujourd'hui en outre il ne
suffira pas d'un coup de baguette
législatives pour créer ces plateformes
à l'échelle de chaque département un
important travail de fond et de
préparation est nécessaire
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
expérimentations proposé à l'article 31
est selon nous un compromis acceptable à
condition que les apports de la
commission des lois soit conservée dans
le texte c'est donc une demande de
retraite ou un avis défavorable a dit
merci madame le rapport faire madame la
ministre les magies madame la présidente
vous remercie une expo qui
a demandé la parole me sur des chars
landais la parole pour explication de
vote ensuite monsieur favreau
le serai bref
mais je dois dire qu'en début d'analysé
de ce projet j'ai partagé la proche de
monsieur favreau en considérant que même
l'expérimentation n'était pas une idée
judicieuse parce que sur le fond je
pense que le été après avoir entendu
plusieurs personnes connaissant bien le
domaine que le numéro unique n'est pas
d'abord n'est pas une nécessité requise
par l'union européenne contrairement à
ce qui a été dit est simplement un
souhait pour les expatriés en europe
mais que ce n'est pas nécessairement une
solution efficace du point de vue de la
bonne gestion des moyens de réponse aux
urgences et notamment sous l'angle
sanitaires
je ne suivrai toutefois pas la formule
de notre collègue parce qu' il existe en
effet déjà des situations de
l'organisation partagés sur un site
unique dans lesquelles les inconvénients
de l'existence de plusieurs numéros si
les sites qui existent peuvent être
surmontés mais le point sur lequel
je ne suis pas en tout cas l'avis qui
vient d'être exprimées par la rapporteur
au nom de la commission c'est que c'est
de partir de l'expérience dont
l'expérimentation en pensant que de
toute façon à la fin le mur unique la
bonne solution
comme ça a été dit par d'autres
collègues il me semble que ce qui est
une nécessité ce qui est un progrès dans
la gestion de ces services publics c'est
la proximité en lieu de travail en
situation travail des réponses aux eaux
en appel de sécurité ou zapper à
caractère sanitaire mais que lumière
unique ne répond pas nécessairement à 7
à cette amélioration est donc je suis
favorable au déroulement de l'expérience
aussi avec comme préoccupation ce que
souhaitait monsieur fabre o c'est à dire
qu' on puisse analyser pendant une
période limitée et sur des dossiers
approfondie les impacts financiers de
ces opérations puisque en réalité chaque
appel d'urgence déclenché en général une
dépense publique et une dépense publique
qui peut être tout à fait substantiel
donc sur l'analyse des modalités fané
qualité des réponses et de l'efficacité
de l'orientation des appels avec les
deux numéros ou avec un numéro partager
mais sur une analyse de durée suffisante
il me semble que c'est la bonne solution
c'est la raison pour laquelle il me
semble qu'il ne faut pas suivre la
proposition de monsieur fabre o merci un
chers collègues me favreau l'explication
de
vous retirer votre abandon
vous ne retirez pas donc nous allons m
nous allons mettre aux voix la maman 19
rectifié biscarrosse et un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre
qui savent qu'elle n'est pas adoptée le
65 rectifié de terre monsieur bourgi le
défend
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame et messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues l'amendement que nous
vous proposons avec un certain nombre de
collègues du groupe socialistes
écologistes et républicains
vise à créer un numéro unique pour les
appels d'urgence il s'agit là d'une
demande qui est très ancienne cela fait
quinze ans qu'elle est dans le débat
public vous le savez cela fait quinze
ans que les directives européennes nous
le demande il s'agit de prendre acte
d'une réalité celle de la singularité de
la sécurité publique à la française
cette singularité elle présente des
atouts elle présente des avantages et
depuis hier nous en parlons et en
particulier en ce qui concerne le
volontariat des sapeurs pompiers mais le
modèle de sécurité publique à la
française il présente aussi des failles
et des limites
juxtaposition de numéros déficits
structurels notamment sur le plan humain
dans certains services je veux en
particulier cité le samu
nous avons besoin de simplifier de
clarifier de rendre plus lisible et
d'augmenter l'efficience de ses services
en réduisant les délais de réponse et
les dires et d'intervention cela fait
maintenant une dizaine d'années que les
gouvernements successifs esquive le
sujet se défile et renvoie la
responsabilité à leurs successeurs
si ce sujet régulièrement renvoyée aux
calendes grecques en multipliant les
expérimentations c'est pour me dit-on
ménager les susceptibilités des uns et
des autres mes chers collègues lorsque
nous sommes au parlement ne sommes pas
et pour ménager les susceptibilités
nous sommes ici pour servir l'intérêt
général nous sommes ici pour agir en
responsabilité
nous sommes ici pour offrir aux
françaises et aux français la sécurité
publique la plus efficace la plus
efficiente la plus rapide la plus
lisible pour ne pas créer le numéro
unique certains me disent il ne faut pas
rallumer la guerre entre les blancs et
les rouges mes chers collègues je
connais au parlement ne sommes pas ici
pour allumer des guerres ne sont pas ici
pour prendre parti pour les uns ou pour
les autres et s'il ya un seul parti que
nous devons tous et tout prendre c'est
le parti des bleu blanc rouge celui des
français et des françaises mes chers
collègues vous avez compris c'est en
responsabilité que nous vous proposons
de prendre acte de la réalité qui a trop
duré et de voter dès à présent la
création de ce numéro unique je vous
remercie merci chers collègues
maintenant passons à l'avis de la
commission madame la rapporteure
dames la présidente le présent
amendement tend à revenir à la version
initiale de l'article 31 qui prévoyait
la création généralisée de plateformes
communes et la mise en place du sens
douce pour les raisons il faut évoquer
lors de l'examen de l'amendement
précédent nous sommes contre cette
rédaction la raison l'important c'est
donc une demande de retrait ou à défaut
un avis défavorable
merci madame la ministre mais magie
madame bien présent merci vous massez
votre amendement eh bien je vais mettre
aux voix le 65 rectifié terre qui a reçu
deux avis défavorables qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient on n'est pas adopté
quatre un moment faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 33 rectifier mais
ceux-ci gaulle et y oui madame la
présidente on aime la ministre mes chers
collègues contenu de la volonté
réaffirmée de nos rapporteur de faire
passer l'expérimentation de trois à deux
ans je retire cet amendement je vous
remercie ses collègues le 33 rectifié
retirer le 137 view madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente ça mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs la
généralisation des plateformes communes
d'appel d'urgence qui regroupe les
services d'incendié et de secours et les
services d'être médicale urgente au
niveau national induite de profond
impact en termes de gouvernance en
termes de territorialité en termes de
doctrine de systèmes d'information de
processus métier compte tenu de la
sensibilité ce sujet le gouvernement
estime préférable de pouvoir rétablir
l'écriture issue des travaux préalables
et des lois de l'assemblée nationale en
raison des équilibres qui ont été
précédemment trouvé sur cet article dur
merci
merci madame la ministre monsieur madame
le rapporteur pardon non pas tout de
suite
excusez moi il ya encore le 49 rectifié
modem tarayre merci madame la présidente
cet amendement a pour objet de
réintroduire dans le texte afin qu'il
soit formalisée au niveau légal le choix
du numéro unique 112 dans la mesure où
ce numéro était expressément désigné
dans le texte initial nous souhaitons
qu'il puisse l'être encore dans cette
nouvelle lecture
merci mme carrère et madame 10 days il
est défendu et donc maintenant vous nous
pouvons passer à la vie de madame le
rapporteur
l'amendement 49 temps à réintroduire la
mention du 112 dans les termes de
l'expérimentation nous savons que cet
ajout n'est pas consensuelle alors qu'il
ne change rien la teneur de
l'expérimentation nous ne souhaitons pas
envenimer un débat qui est déjà
suffisamment tendue c'est une demande de
retrait wade vous faut un avis
défavorable pour l'amendement 49
l'amendement 29 de madame guide est en a
mentionné que l'expérimentation sera mis
en place en lien avec l'association
départementale des transports sanitaires
urgents or le dispositif prévu par
l'article fixe déjà comme objectif de
faciliter et d'accélérer
c'est au samu la déclinaison
réglementaire de l'expérimentation
pourra prévoir une consultation de
l'association départementale des
transports sanitaires urgents sans qu'il
soit besoin de le prévoir dans la loi en
outre votre amendement supprime la
référence aux associations agrées de
sécurité civile à laquelle nous tenons
c'est une demande de retrait ou à défaut
un avis défavorable
enfin l'amendement 137 du gouvernement
tend à revenir sur l'ensemble des
apports de la commission des lois la vie
est logiquement défavorable et nous
interroge madame la ministre comment
justifier que l'on écarte les
associations agréées de sécurité civile
du dispositif alors que leurs bénévoles
jouent un rôle fondamental auprès de nos
concitoyens
il s'agit là véritablement d'une
injustice envers eux comment mettre en
place des expérimentations à l'échelle
supra départementale alors que le
département est l'échelle d'action de la
sécurité civile aidés ce 10 ce serait
donc aux acteurs locaux de s'adapter à
l'échelle des ars alors qu'il serait
beaucoup plus simple et efficace de
faire l' inverse comment réintroduire
l'expérimentation
donc comment réintroduire
l'expérimentation du regroupement du 15
et de la permanence des soins alors
qu'une telle expérimentation ne concerne
en rien la sécurité civile cette mesure
est étrangère à ce texte elle ne
concerne que la santé et devrait avoir
sa place dans un texte sur la santé mais
pas sur la sécurité civile enfin comment
pouvez-vous exclure les présidents des
conseils d'administration de ce 10 du
pilotage de ces expérimentations alors
qu'elles vont concerner leur personnel
et leurs moyens il n'est pas normal que
seul l'état décide alors que ce sont les
collectivités qui vont financer en
première ligne desquels les départements
je vous l'indiquais en toute franchise
ces modifications ne sont pas
admissibles pour nous
on peut résumer madame la présidente
c'est donc une demande de retrait pour
ou avis défavorable pour les amendements
29 et 49 et un avis franchement
défavorable aux 137 merci et madame le
rapporteur madame la ministre vous avez
la parole pour l'avis du gouvernement
les âges défavorable pour les autres
amendements je vous remercie et je mets
donc aux voix pour commencer
l'amendement 137 du gouvernement qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
n'est pas adopté il y à une demande de
retrait de la commission sur le
49 il est retiré il est retiré et sur le
29 il est retiré aussi je vous remercie
et donc nous passons aux soixante dix
rectifié by cc monsieur chassaing qu'il
défend
même la présidente
madame et messieurs mes chers collègues
alors si l'expérimentation proposées par
cet article est une étape essentielle et
indispensable dans l'objectif d'un
numéro unique d'appel d'urgence il faut
ce moment en préciser certains aspects
relatifs à son application tout d'abord
comme l'a dit olivier cigolotti la
plateforme doit être absolument
départementale
l'amélioration de la prise en charge des
personnes étant le point central de
l'expérimentation il est important que
la gestion des appels et les décisions
prises en matière de santé face à
l'urgence de la situation reste entre
les mains du médecin régulateur il ne
peut pas y avoir deux ou plusieurs
médecins lors de l'appel en rapport avec
la santé au risque de perdre en
efficacité
durant l'intervention je voudrais
rappeler et c'est l'amendement donc
monsieur fabre au quilit à des
départements où le 18 et le quinson sur
un même site et qu'il n'y a pas du tout
de guerre ça se passe donc très bien
donc il faut faire une expérimentation
et parce que les médecins du samu ont
certaines craintes alors les appels
d'offres donc être automatiquement
passer aux médecins glas du samu pour
toutes les situations en rapport avec la
santé tel est l'objet de cet amendement
merci chers collègues avis de la
commission
c'est une demande de retrait ou à défaut
un avis défavorable cet amendement tend
à préciser que les expérimentations ne
remettront pas en cause les prérogatives
du médecin régulateur nous souhaitons
rassurer son auteur car
l'expérimentation ne mets pas en cause
les prérogatives du médecin régulateur
les plateformes existence se sont
d'ailleurs constitué à droit constant et
ne semble pas avoir remis en cause les
fondamentaux de la règlement de la
régulation dans l'hypothèse où un modèle
de plateforme serait pérennisé la
commission a souhaité préciser que le
référentiel de fonctionnement des
plateformes devraient notamment garantir
le respect du secret médical et ne remet
pas en cause la mission de régulation
médicale et le service d'accès aux soins
c'est donc une demande de retrait ou
avis défavorable merci madame la
ministre
demande de retrait également madame la
présidente je vous remercie
mais c'est ça st we do qu au vu de ce
qu'il vient le d'expliquer le modem le
rapporteur je retire mon amendement
merci chers collègues le soixante dix
rectifié retirer le 41 et présenté par
madame brulin merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
cet article 31 prévoyait initialement la
mise en place définitive d'un numéro
unique le 112 et la mutualisation des
plateformes d'appels des 10 et des samu
notamment cependant l'assemblée
nationale a fait marche arrière et la
remplacer par une expérimentation de
plate forme commune de réception des
appels d'urgence avec plusieurs
configurations possibles des
interrogations demeurent sur cette
expérimentation c'est l'objet de notre
débat de ce matin qui a prioris frais au
niveau départemental malgré des
modifications effectuées en commission
des lois cet article reste finalement
assez peu clair sur l'organisation des
expérimentations et l'objectif final de
celle-ci est ce qui nous a
particulièrement étonné et des collègues
des départements concernés et en font
ils en ont fait mention ir pas une seule
fois n'est fait état de l'existence de
telles plateformes dans plusieurs
départements aujourd'hui
en effet depuis plusieurs années
maintenant il en existe des ces types de
plateau commun qui montre la efficacité
au quotidien dans le même objectif que
le présent article ces plateformes sont
rattachés aux 15 au 18 voire au 115 et
nous pourrons nous semble légitime
d'insérer d'intégrer ces
expérimentations actuelle dans celle qui
signifierait à la suite de ce texte de
loi d'une part avec la remise par le
gouvernement au parlement d'un bilan
d'activité de ces plateformes et d'autre
part nous souhaitons préciser que ces
plateformes pré existantes seront
associés aux départements nouvellement
expérimentateurs une expérience de
terrain doit être prise en compte il
nous semble logique qu'on puisse s'en
servir et c'est là le sens de cet
amendement qui porte également la
volonté d'inclusion des acteurs de la
sécurité civile d'autres l'ont dit aussi
déjà engagées sur ces plateaux notamment
dans le projet nexis 18-12 qui se
développe en parallèle merci merci
madame moulin
madame la rapporteure pour l'avis de la
commission madame la présidente le
présent amendement tend à préciser que
l'expérimentation prévue à l'article 31
devra s'appuyer sur l'expérience issus
de nombreuses plateformes communes de
réception des appels d'urgence déjà
existantes et pour rassurer madame la
sénatrice monsieur loïc harvey et moi
même si nous sommes personnellement
déplacé annecy pour en expérience de
terrain pour nous rendre compte de
l'excellent fonctionnement de la
plateforme qui existe en ce lieu et que
le modèle fonctionne fort bien entre les
différents services qui partagent
l'endroit cette idée me semble donc
relever du bon sens il devrait il serait
dommage de s'en priver c'est donc un
avis favorable à votre demande
merci madame la ministre a dit favorable
à la reprise je vous remercie madame ce
logo pour explication de vote
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre moi je vais aussi voté cet
amendement parce que je voulais rappeler
qu'il ya également des expérimentations
de regroupement régional je suis élu de
la nièvre et nous sommes sur une plate
forme actuellement régionales il est bon
aussi d'avoir le retour d'expérience de
ce modèle est également merci madame
sollogoub je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement 41 créé ces deux avis
favorables qui est pour et qui est
contre ça ben said est adoptée les 42
rectifié bis mana brulin toujours merci
madame la présidente avec cet amendement
nous proposons de renforcer les
garanties relatives à l'expérimentation
de plate forme commune d'appel d'urgence
et du numéro unique en particulier en ce
qui concerne les données personnelles et
les données de santé le développement du
numérique notamment dans l'activité de
secours et d'urgence terme est
évidemment d'accroître l'efficacité
notamment la rapidité
ce qui évidemment essentiel mais cela
appelle un encadrement strict du
traitement des données qui doit
accompagner cette numérisation je vais
pas développer sur les gars femmes et
l'intérêt tout particulier
qu'elles ont à l'égard de ces données et
donc il nous semble nécessaire de
préciser dans le détail que l'axé les
modalités et les conditions d'accès aux
marchés publics des 10 dans le cadre des
opérations de secours et d'urgence
seront fixés selon des règles assurant
des garanties quant à la protection de
ces données ce jour merci merci cher
collègue madame là à porter
cet amendement est contraire à la
position de la commission il tend à ce
qu'un décret précise les modalités et
les conditions d'accès aux marchés
publics des services d'incendié et de
secours afin de garantir la protection
des données de santé et d'autres données
personnelles dans le cadre des
opérations de secours d'urgence le
problème du secret médical est il est
vrai très sensible toutefois leur
protection ne passe pas nécessairement
par des adaptations ou droit commun de
la commande publique mais plutôt par les
normes et à gré man qui s'applique à au
dispositif et instruments médicaux pour
autoriser leur utilisation et leur
commercialisation
en outre cet amendement vient s'imputer
à l'article 31 qui concerne une
expérimentation c'est donc une demande
de retrait ou à défaut un avis
défavorable si même le rapporteur même
la ministre
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs à madame la
sénatrice vous savez que l'état
particulièrement engagé en faveur des 10
dans la sécurisation de leurs données
notamment eu égard à la sensibilité de
ces données et sans pouvoir ici en
dévoiler le détail pour des raisons que
chacun comprendra toutes les actions qui
sont entreprises par les services
d'incendié et de secours de l'état je
peux vous assurer que la direction
générale de la sécurité civile et de la
gestion des crises en lien étroit avec
l' agence nationale de la sécurité des
systèmes d'information accompagne les
services d'incendié et secours dans le
renforcement de leurs pratiques et dans
le renforcement des outils en matière de
sécurité des systèmes d'information je
veux vous dire que le futur système de
gestion de la leyre tenez xi skies est
développé par l' agence du numérique de
la sécurité civile et qui a vocation à
être déployé dans l'ensemble des six
bénéficie également de cette sécurité
des systèmes d'information conçu
nativement grâce à l expertise des
cadres du ministère de l'intérieur que
je veux saluer la détermination par
décret de l'accès des modalités et des
conditions d'accès aux marchés publics
des services d'incendié et de secours
afin de garantir la protection des
données de santé et d autres données
personnelles dans le cadre des
opérations de secours et d'urgence ne
nous apparaît donc pas nécessaire vous
proposons de retirer cet amendement je
vous remercie je mets donc vous malgré
l'amendement donc je mets aux voileux 42
rectifié qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui et pour
qui et contre qui savent cei n'est pas
adoptée jeux move l article 31 kg et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient elle
est adoptée
voilà vous avez suivi les débats autour
de la proposition de loi sur le
volontariat
des sapeurs pompiers adopté à
l'unanimité le 23 septembre dernier ce
texte consensuel prévoit des avantages
sociaux et une plus grande
reconnaissance des sacrifices réalisés
par les pompiers vous pouvez retrouvez
le résumé de cette séance dans l'article
pompiers volontaires que contient le
texte adopté par le sénat sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
à très bientôt
le réchauffement climatique est en cours
et bouleverse déjà notre monde
dans ce dérèglement qui nous menace tous
les états unis restent les plus gros
émetteurs mondiaux de co2 par habitant
dans leurs besoins énergétiques sont
colossaux
l'extraction frénétique des gaz de
schiste ravages des régions entières
les nappes phréatiques sont pollués au
méthane et l'eau n'est plus consommable
alors qu'il ya urgence à agir au niveau
mondial beaucoup d'américains continuent
à nier l'existence du changement
climatique et on en fait depuis les
années 2000 une question partisane qui
déchirent toujours les états unis
[Musique]
pourquoi un tel acharnement à nier la
réalité
lima une guerre américaine samedi à 21h
sur public sénat
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public 90
minutes pour débattre pour vous donner
des clés de compréhension de l'actualité
et des mutations profondes de notre
société de la société française avec
comme chaque soir trois temps forts dans
l'émission d'abord un débat d'actualité
sera consacrée aujourd'hui au ras-le-bol
des généralistes sos médecins en grève
pour alerter sur le risque de
disparition des visites à domicile des
libéraux surchargé qui ont de moins en
moins de temps pour leurs patients des
déserts médicaux de plus en plus
nombreux on va essayé d'esquisser des
pistes de sortie de crise juste après
ses titres mal les électeurs ont la
parole dans cette rubrique quotidienne
vous nous alerter sur un fait
d'actualité sur ce que vous attendez des
candidats à la présidentielle ou tout
simplement de vos élus aujourd'hui c'est
la loi sur les pneus neige obligatoires
dans 48 départements à partir du 1er
novembre qui vous fait bondir notamment
en ariège où en sera tout à l'heure et
puis troisième temps fort notre débat
décalé plus prospectif et justement on
va s'appuyer ce soir sur le livre de
david djaïz le nouveau modèle français
pour chercher des alternatives aux
discours décliniste et se projeter dans
ce 21e siècle mais d'abord mais d'abord
sos médecins qui alerte sur sa possible
disparition les soixante trois
associations de médecins libéraux ont
annoncé un arrêt total de leurs
activités pour aujourd'hui jusqu'à
demain pour obtenir une augmentation de
leurs tarifs cécile 6 ou
alexandra et médecin aux urgences
médicales de paris normalement elle fait
des visites au domicile des patients
mais ce matin comme ses collègues des
sceaux est médecin elle fait grève et
sur les groupes whatsapp du samu auquel
elle est inscrite ça s'affole ils ont
besoin d'être plus nombreux du coup au
samu pour prendre à tous les appels que
sos médecins et nous ne faisons que pas
régulé aujourd'hui quoi pour ces visites
à domicile alexandra et payer 35 euros
trop peu selon elle les médecins
traitants qui font ponctuellement le
même travail sont beaucoup mieux payé
pour un patient de plus de 70 ans qui a
un sens pour cent c'est à dire qu'ils en
affection longue durée et qui est à son
domicile qui n'est pas hospitalisée un
médecin traitant s'il va le voir quatre
fois dans l'année il va pouvoir au lieu
de 35 euros être payé 70 euros pour ses
consultants la 4e valorisation là on n'y
a pas droit nous alors qu'on est aussi
médecin généraliste et donc c'est un peu
en france elles demandent une
revalorisation de ses consultations à
57,60 euros une revalorisation
nécessaire d'autant que le métier attire
de moins en moins les jeunes médecins
eux ce qu'ils aiment c'est travailler
dans des centres de santé où
tout est un petit peu clé en main et
nous en fait c'est un métier qui est
complètement différent travaillent nuit
et jour